gedenken in auschwitz vor 75 jahren
befreit die rote armee das
konzentrations und vernichtungslager
heute appellieren überlebende an die
welt es dürfe keine gleichgültigkeit
geben die erinnerung müsse bewahrt
werden
das coruna virus breitet sich aus
weltweit steigt die zahl der infizierten
china reisen werden abgesagt trauer um
us basketball legende kobe bryant stirbt
bei einem hubschrauber absturz in der
nähe von los angeles
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten am 27 januar einem
historischen datum
mit dabei für den sport norbert lehmann
guttenberg von mir heute vor 75 jahren
erreichte die sowjetische rote armee das
ns-vernichtungslager auschwitz-birkenau
und fand unfassbares vor auch 7007
tausend überlebende die dem horror der
deutschen vernichtungsmaschinerie knapp
entronnen waren heute erinnert die welt
in auschwitz an die verbrechen der
deutschen bundespräsident steinmeier
traf sich am morgen im schloss bellevue
mit überlebenden bevor sie gemeinsam zur
gedenkfeier nach polen reisten die
erinnerungen an die zeit im lager sind
noch immer lebendig vergessen
das bleibt drin stecken wenn jemand mal
eingeschlafen nicht immer dann träume
und schreie immer nur und bin das 86
jahre alt ich empfinde trauer weil ich
reise zum graben meiner mutter meiner
kleinen schwester und meiner großeltern
sind in auschwitz ermordet worden
wenn man das hört kann man nur ahnen was
die ehemaligen kz-häftlinge durchgemacht
haben und warum auschwitz zum synonym
für den holocaust für das böse
schlechthin steht auschwitz war das
größte deutsche konzentrations und
vernichtungslager 1940 hatten die
nationalsozialisten mit dem bau in der
nähe der heute südpolnischen stadt
tianjin begonnen
wegen der zentralen lage im deutsch
besetzten europa wurden circa 1,3
millionen menschen aus fast allen
regionen nach auschwitz deportiert
mehr als eine million juden aber auch
politisch verfolgte kriegsgefangene roma
sind die homosexuelle zeugen jehovas
auschwitz bestand aus drei haupt und
mehr als 40 nebenlagern das größte
hauptlager entstand 1941 auschwitz
birkenau in mehr als 300 baracken waren
zeitweise rund 90.000 menschen
gleichzeitig untergebracht die meisten
deportierten wurden direkt nach ihrer
ankunft in den gaskammern ermordet und
dann verbrannt
die übrigen häftlinge mussten arbeiten
bis zur tödlichen erschöpfung viele
starben durch krankheit unterernährung
und misshandlungen
insgesamt wurden etwa 1,1 millionen
menschen hier ermordet auschwitz wurde
zum symbol des industriell organisierten
massenmordes am 27 januar 1945
schließlich wurde das lager durch
truppen der roten armee befreit
in einer zeit des wachsenden
antisemitismus und extremismus ist die
erinnerung an das was geschehen ist von
großer bedeutung
das sagen nicht nur überlebende zumal es
nicht mehr lange menschen geben wird die
das grauen am eigenen leib erfahren
haben
bei der gedenkfeier in auschwitz heute
standen denn auch sie ganz im zentrum
christoph distel wieder zurück am ort
ihrer unvorstellbaren leiden
sie waren die opfer haben überlebt und
wollen müssen sich jetzt erinnern damit
auch die übrige welt sich erinnert es
ist gegen neun uhr morgens im hauptlager
auschwitz dort wo die nazis häftlinge
erschossen legen sie kränze nieder
9 uhr der moment als die rote armee das
lager befreiten 200 überlebende sind
noch angereist jeder und jede mit einem
auschwitz schicksal und jede ihrer
geschichten bezeugt den rassenwahn der
nazis
ich war vier monate alt bei meiner
mutter auf dem arm sie musste sich in
die schlange zu den gaskammern stellen
wir kamen immer näher als mich einer der
deutschen sah und blondes baby mit
blauen augen nur deswegen name meine
mutter zur seite und sagte ihr werdet
nicht sterben nur wegen meines aussehens
auch der deutsche präsident steinmeier
ist da nicht zum rede halten
der tag soll den opfern gehören aber
steinmeier trägt sich ins gedenkbuch ein
und schreibt wer den weg in die barbarei
von auschwitz kennt der muss den
anfängen wehren und dann am nachmittag
das offizielle gedenken in einem zelt
das sie um den eingang von auschwitz
birkenau herum gebaut haben
der blick auf die bühne geht auch das
tor dass so viele menschen direkt in den
tod führte vier überlebende sprechen
oder weil sie blind ist lassen sprechen
die aus hamburg stammende elsa baker 85
jahre alt sind die mit acht ins lager
gekommen so erinnert sie sich an das
grauen
ohrenbetäubende schreie draußen waren zu
hören und ich ein kleines mädchen hörte
die gespräche der anderen häftlinge in
muss das gas ausgegangen seien
also verbrennen sie die menschen leben
[Musik]
dann stanislaw zalewski 94 jähriger pole
drei konzentrationslager hat er überlebt
dinge gesehen die kaum zu ertragen waren
und auch im rückblick nicht sind um
normal leben zu können versuche ich
nicht daran zu denken was geschah habe
meine erinnerung in eine schachtel
gepackt und sie ins wasser geworfen nur
ganz selten hole ich sie wieder raus und
marian turski polnischer journalist 93
todesmarsch überlebender sieht nach form
mahnt die nächste generation seit nicht
gleichgültig wenn ihr lügen sid und wenn
es historische lügen sind seit nicht
gleichgültig
zumal erweist und es auch ausspricht
augenzeugen wie er werden beim nächsten
gedenkt tag in auschwitz vielleicht
nicht mehr da sein
natalie steger hat den tag in auschwitz
heute miterlebt natalie was macht dieses
gedenken am 75 jahrestag zu einem
besonderen ja es war wirklich ein
besonderes gedenken weil die
überlebenden im mittelpunkt standen es
sollte ein gedenken zeichen der
überlebenden seien
man wollte keine großen politischen
reden man wollte ihre stimmen hören die
stimmen die vielleicht nicht mehr lange
zu hören sind man wollte ihre berichte
ihre erzählungen ihre zeitzeugenschaft
und es war schon sehr bemerkenswert wie
sie berichteten und was sie sagen und
auch in persönlichen gesprächen haben
wir das hier immer wieder erlebt da
herrscht wenig wut erstaunlicherweise es
herrscht sehr viel trauer aber auch sehr
persönliches man möchte nach vorne
blicken die das grauen erlebt haben
mahnen sie sagen es werden immer noch
auf der welt minderheiten diskriminiert
wehret den anfängen es ihre botschaft
damit so etwas grauenvolles wie
auschwitz auch nicht einmal im ansatz
noch einmal passieren kann
danke in sehr natalie steger die
befreiung von auschwitz 1945
ausführliche dokumentationen zum lager
und zum holocaust haben wir auf heute de
zusammengestellt
dort gibt es auch weitere berichte von
zeitzeugen von menschen also die
auschwitz überlebt haben nach china
wegen des corona virus erwägt die
bundesregierung ausreisewillige deutsche
aus den betroffenen regionen
auszufliegen
erste deutsche reiseveranstalter bieten
ihren kunden an reisen nach china
umzubuchen oder zu stornieren
dort stieg die zahl der toten auf 81 das
sind 25 mehr als gestern erkrankt sind
nach offiziellen angaben 2744 rund 700
mehr außerhalb von china wurden
insgesamt 50 fälle gemeldet darunter in
australien nordamerika und europa luton
leinhos berichtet
der premier kommt dem kittel und mit
mundschutz nach hahn
chinas politische führung ist alarmiert
lief er spricht schnell für mehr
personal und ausrüstung zu sorgen die
klinikmitarbeiter stört eher dramatisch
ein
bleibt gesund und schützt euer leben
euer job ist es andere leben zu retten
im ganzen land hängen die menschen von
euch ab der ansturm auf die
krankenhäuser ist riesig von teils
chaotischen zuständen berichten
augenzeugen sowie diese chinesin aus
deutschland house die pico ist mit
service enorme gesunden die erkälteten
und normale grippe patienten werden
vermischt mit denen die sich wirklich
mit dem corona virus infiziert haben
während sie alle gemeinsam auf den arzt
warten verbreitet sich die infektion
chinas behörden räumen ein noch zu wenig
über das virus zu wissen zwischen
infektionen und symptomen vergehen zwei
bis 14 tage sagen sie und behaupten dass
der erreger schon während dieser
inkubationszeit übertragbar sei
deutschlands führender virologe zweifelt
bin darüber sehr überrascht denn alle
anderen parameter die wir kennen über
diese erkrankung sagen mir dass wir hier
eigentlich eine typische saß erkrankung
vor uns haben und bei saas ist es nicht
so gewesen dass symptomatische patienten
normalerweise diese erkrankung schon
übertragen konnten sollten erkrankte
ohne symptome tatsächlich das corona
virus übertragen können wäre es viel
schwerer seine ausbreitung einzudämmen
berlin überlegt nun deutsche auswahl
zurück zu holen
auch in betracht eine mögliche
evakuierung ausreisewillige deutsche
laut bundesregierung halten sich rund 90
deutsche in der gegend auf vor einer
evakuierung neuen viele noch abwarten
inzwischen gibt es auch in peking einen
ersten todesfall
ein 50 jähriger erlag heute der
krankheit er hatte wo hahn besucht und
nach st
rückkehr fieber bekommen im
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen
us-präsident trump drängen die
demokraten mehr und mehr darauf dass im
senat neue zeugen gehört werden
besonders hilfreich wäre da aus ihrer
sicht der frühere nationale
sicherheitsberater john bolton der in
einem noch nicht erschienenen buch
offenbar schwere vorwürfe gegen trump
erhebt trump so heißt es dort habe
tatsächlich militärhilfe an die ukraine
so lange zurückhalten wollen
bis ihm das land bei ermittlungen gegen
seinen kontrahenten beiden helfer eines
traums er lässt eine bombe platzen
mitten im amtsenthebungsverfahren john
bolton der ehemalige sicherheitsberater
von präsident trump laut der new york
times schreibt er in seinem noch
unveröffentlichten buch das trump fast
400 millionen dollar militärhilfe der
ukraine nur stellen wollte wenn die
gegen seinen politischen rivalen joe
biden ermittelt aussage gegen aussage
kam der zur stunde den israelischen
ministerpräsidenten netanjahu empfängt
widerspricht ich habe das manuskript
noch nicht gesehen aber ich kann ihnen
sagen so etwas in der art habe ich nie
gesagt ich denke boten will einfach nur
ein buch schreiben bodens darstellung
gibt dem team der demokraten im
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen trump neue
munition
sie wollen zeugen wie boten hören die
republikaner haben das bislang mit ihrer
mehrheit im senat abgeschmettert
wir haben nun einen zeugen der selber
die handlungen des präsidenten
beobachtet hat für die er angeklagt ist
wurden ist bereit auszusagen
wie können die republikaner ihn nicht
als zeugen wollen vier republikanische
senatoren müssen die demokraten auf ihre
seite ziehen erste wackelkandidaten gibt
es bereits mit dem bericht er nun
vorliegt ist es wichtig von john boten
zu hören
ich denke es ist wahrscheinlich dass
auch andere republikanische senatoren
dafür stimmen werden ihm als zeugen zu
hören
mit netanjahu will trump einen
friedensplan für den nahen
osten vorstellen für ihn eine gelungene
möglichkeit sich als tatkräftiger
staatsmann zu geben und vom
amtsenthebungsverfahren abzulenken
jetzt also trumps friedensplan für
nahost frage an elmar theveßen unseren
korrespondenten in washington
aber wie sehen denn seine vorschläge
überhaupt aus ja die details will donald
trump morgen mit benjamin netanjahu
gemeinsam bei einer pressekonferenz hier
im weißen haus vorstellen aber am rande
seines treffens mit netanjahu und danach
auch mit dessen politischen widersacher
benny gantz zeichnet sich doch ab dass
amerika einen schwenk vollziehen will
das meer dieser friedensplan
israelischen interessen entsprechen soll
das könnte beinhalten dass die
us-regierung ablenkt oder abrückt besser
gesagt von einer zwei staaten lösung
also dass die palästinenser tatsächlich
auch einen staat bekämen das wäre dann
vom tisch das würde weder den
palästinensern noch den europäern
gefallen die alle an der entwicklung
dieses plans dieses jahrhundert plans
wie trampe nennt nicht beteiligt waren
das timing ist interessant sowohl
benjamin netanjahu als auch dort stehen
ja innenpolitisch unter druck es wird er
mittels sie sind im wahlkampf und das
zeigt dass es sich hier vielleicht eher
um gegenseitige wahlkampfhilfe handeln
wird es wird morgen an den details zu
sehen sein ob dieser sogenannte
jahrhundert plan irgendeine chance auf
verwirklichung beinhaltet
tja dann wissen wir mehr vielen dank
elmar theveßen nach washington nach
italien zu der regionalwahl in der
emilia romagna
dort kämpft der oppositionschef matteo
salvini mit seiner rechtspopulistischen
lega für einen sieg und erlebte eine
niederlage sei wenig partei erhielt 43,6
prozent der stimmen mit einem erfolg in
der traditionell linken region wollte
salvini den rücktritt der regierung in
rom und neuwahlen erzwingen
gewonnen haben jedoch die regierenden
sozialdemokraten mit 51,4 nur zu dir
norbert ja die sportwelt um eine
basketball legende um kobe bryant einer
der größten spieler aller zeiten
der fünfmalige nba champion kam gestern
in der nähe von los angeles bei einem
hubschrauberabsturz ums leben zusammen
mit seiner 13 jährigen tochter und
sieben anderen insassen soulsängerin
alicia keys hatte tränen in den augen
bei der grammy verleihung in los angeles
genau in der arena in der kobe bryant
zwei jahrzehnte lang für die lakers
gespielt hatte fans in aller welt
trauern
amerika ist fassungslos basketball wird
nie mehr so sein wie vorher an einem
berghang in kalifornien zerschellte der
helikopter unter den neun toten kobe
bryant und seine zweitälteste tochter
denner mit 17 bei der jüngste profi
seinerzeit gewann fünf meistertitel und
zweimal olympia gold auch dirk nowitzki
zeigte sich betroffen vom tod bryans
dessen ausnahmestellung der letzte woche
noch so beschrieben hatte er konnte so
auch so ein bisschen aber alles war
wahnsinnig athletisch konnte immer
spieler übernehmen und er war der erste
sportler der sich mit hand- und
fußabdrücke auf dem boulevard in
hollywood verewigt
woher auch einen oscar für einen
trickfilm über basketball erhielt man
hat immer auf ihn hoch geschaut dass
alles was erreicht hat unglaublich wird
immer eine legende bleiben champion und
natürlich ist es ja es ist unfassbar
traurig kobe und jenna bryant
hinterlassen ehefrau und mutter vanessa
und jonas zwei schwestern ja die sport
welt erschüttert auch in melbourne bei
den australian open angelique kerber
haben wir ja gerade gehört während die
siegerin von 2016 die achtelfinalspiele
verlor ist deutschlands bester
tennisspieler alexanders wäre eine runde
weiter streicheleinheiten für den
jugendfreund andere immobilie gibt es
erst hinterher im spiel wäre seine
punkte zu setzen wie nadelstiche mit
variablem spiel
nach sechs zu vier im ersten satz bringt
eines von elf assen den zweiten satz
gewinnen wäre verdient sich seine
viertelfinal premiere in australien
durch ein selbstbewusstes auftreten auch
im dritten satz dreimal sechs zu viel
für den deutschen
im viertelfinale wartet nun der
schweizer wawrinka das war heute
eigentlich wohl gefühlt von anfang an
bis zum ende und dann ist auch in gut
gelaufen für mich für angelique kerber
läuft es anfangs auch gut die
australian-open-siegerin 20/16 dreht den
ersten satz gegen anastasia
pawljutschenkowa gewinnt im tie break
der zweite geht mit dem gleichen
resultat an die russin
ich habe alles was ich konnte auf dem
platz gelassen heute kann mir nichts
vorwerfen und das ist immer das
wichtigste am ende verlassen kerber die
kräfte 26 gegen ihre bis dato stärkste
gegnerin
dennoch kann sie melbourne erhobenen
hauptes verlassen prozessbeginn gegen
den früheren skilangläufer johannes dürr
in innsbruck der österreicher ist wegen
verstößen gegen das anti-doping-gesetz
und gewerbsmässigen schweren
sportbetrugs angeklagte hatte mit seinen
aussagen die ermittlungen gegen das
doping netzwerk rund um den erfurter
sportmediziner mag es ausgelöst und hat
sich heute vor gericht teilweise
schuldig bekannt
ja und droht eine haftstrafe von bis zu
fünf jahren
wir haben noch das wetter da wird es
morgen stürmisch und es gibt kräftige
schauer und gewitter mit schnee regen
und graupel die aussichten gleich von
katja für das heute journal mit claus
kleber um 21 uhr 45
wir danken dass sie dabei waren und
verabschieden uns an dieser stelle sind
aber morgen wieder hier punkt 19 uhr
einen schönen abend für sie
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren das
sind stürmische aussichten heute nacht
ist es erstmal ruhig aber schon morgen
früh geht es los mit dem sturm von den
vogesen hier
vormittags gibt es dann die sturmböen
vor allen dingen den süddeutschland auf
den bergen aber auch entlang der
nordseeküste bis morgen abend allerdings
flaut der wind bereits wieder merklich
ab die ersten kräftigen gewitter gibt
schon in der zweiten nachthälfte hier
westlich des rheins sonst sind viele
regenschauer unterwegs und in den
mittelgebirgen ist auch schneeregen
dabei es kann glatt werden in sachsen
und auch in bayern der dort sinken die
temperaturen oft plus 3 bis minus 1 grad
entlang des rheins und zwischen ruhe und
oder bleibt es milder bei 8 bis 4 grad
und morgen ist es dann für uns alle
recht mild mit höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 4 und 9 grad und es gibt
wirklich kräftige regenschauer und
gewitter mit schnee mit schneeregen mit
hagel und auch mit regen in
norddeutschland bleibt es beim regen und
es gibt diesen sehr kräftigen wird
sturmböen müssen wir erwarten und zwar
zum einen auf den bergen im alpenvorland
aber auch immer dann wenn gerade so ein
gewitter über uns hinweg zieht sehr
günstiges wetter gibt es dann auch
nochmal mittwoch der donnerstag wird
ruhiger der freitag milder
schönen abend noch